good afternoon or evening
hi I'm glad actually to see some faces
in the audience that I've not recalled
from our previous five lectures so let
me introduce myself I'm Jacqueline
Goldsby I'm a professor of English thank
you
those are my awesome students I'm a
professor of English and African
American Studies I'm also chair the
African American Studies department here
at Yale and I'm very lucky actually to
be teaching the course that propels this
lecture series forward James Baldwin's
American scene this is this year's
Frankie's seminar in the humanities and
I want to shank as I always do Richard
and Barbara Frankie for supporting this
series for allowing us to think as
broadly and deeply as we have been these
last weeks and for again I just can't
tell you how much it means to all of us
to be able to teach and learn at the
scale that we do so thank you mr. mrs.
Frankie I'm so glad you're here
a few other points as I mentioned this
is the fifth of six public lectures that
are part of this series that accompanies
the course we have one more talk to come
we have a bit of a break the next talk
will be on Tuesday December 6th Chris
LeBron who teaches in African American
Studies in philosophy here at Yale will
talk to us about Baldwin's philosophy of
love that will be 5:30 here at the
Whitney Center but I'm going to hazard a
risk here and suggest that you save the
date because it looks like we might be
able to add a very special film
screening to the calendar in November
we're hoping for November 17th to screen
Raoul pecks new film I am NOT your negro
here at Yale you might have been reading
about this film which is recently
debuted at the Toronto Film Festival the
New York Film Festival as one of the
most important after the price of the
ticket the Karen Thorson and Doug what
is your last name
Dempsey thank you brought to us and
still remains central to our
understanding of Baldwin this film will
complement and extend their work in ways
that I'm at I'm absolutely eager to see
this movie I'm not your Negro is based
on Baldwin's unfinished manuscript
remember this house on his meditation on
the murders that involve one's words
devastated my universe I'm talking about
the murders of Medgar Evers Malcolm X
and Martin Luther King pecks film as I
mentioned has debuted at the Toronto
Film Festival Festival the New York Film
Festival critics at the black film blog
shadow and act call it a haunting
exceptional film The New York Times
declared the film to be the must-see
documentary of the season so we're
aiming for November 17th probably around
6 o'clock we will know for sure whether
or not we're able to screen this it
looks like we can but I'm hoping that
will be the day
so check the Whitney humanities Center's
website and click on the link for this
class the James Baldwin's American scene
and you'll know by next Friday if we're
going forward with it but it will be
November 17th probably six o'clock ish
it will probably be the only time that
this film is shown in Connecticut
otherwise you'll have to go to New York
to see it so take advantage of that and
again we have to thank mr. mrs. Frankie
for making that possible a couple other
things I want to give as always to the
Whitney humanities centers staff Gary
Tomlinson who's the director the office
staff Sandra Malin Bowles and as always
Tony sue doll who's like had me wired up
here for 21st century sound he does
amazing work for us and I appreciate it
and also my graduate assistant Phoenix
Alexander who really does attend to
every single detail that makes the work
of this painless but now let me
introduce our speaker our speaker today
is Professor Magdalena Zab rosca who
teaches in the department's of American
culture and afro-american and after in
African Studies at the University of
Michigan Ann Arbor she writes and
teaches broadly and creatively across
the span of 20th century American and
African American literature's from a
decidedly global lens as hinted by the
title of her first book how we found
America reading gender through East
European immigrant narratives and the
book that brings her to our series today
James Baldwin's Turkish decade erotics
of exile that book which justly won the
Modern Language Association z-- William
s Scarborough prize awarded to the best
book in african-american literary and
cultural studies in 2008 charted a new
crucial direction in Baldwin studies let
me briefly explain why we know so much
about Baldwin's famous rejection of the
United States for Paris and when he left
New York for that city
in 1948 we also know quite a bit about
his seven years stay that brought us
such classic work says go tell it on the
mountain Giovanni's Room in the essay
the stranger in the village James
Baldwin's Turkish decade expands the
maps we've used to chart Baldwin's
global career in this stunning work
professors at Brusco recovers the
10-year period between 1961 to 1971 when
Baldwin's transatlantic commuting to use
his phrase landed him in Istanbul Turkey
there Baldwin found a vital home space
or as he would put it a place to dwell
where he experienced much needed peace
solace community and productivity
detaching himself from the frenzied Fame
that defined his role as a leading
public intellectual in the u.s. civil
rights movement choosing to reject the
seductions and corruptions of Western
Europe's conceptions of race gender
class and power Baldwin was able in
Istanbul to explore his sensual self
this is a term that comes from his work
to fire the next time the term that I
take and we've been discussing in class
as a theory as a concept about modeling
open reciprocal experience and
acceptance he's able to explore his
sensual self in Istanbul put another way
in an important term says the Broce that
recovers Baldwin embraced his same-sex
love himself in Istanbul indeed his
queer self appears more fully in his
social relationships and in his writing
from Istanbul in this regard
Magda's book is more than a
groundbreaking biography which it is by
any and all accounts the books equally
impressive accomplishment stems from the
wage she traces what she calls the
Turkish imprint on what critics have
heretofore dismissed as Baldwin's late
and supposedly less formally
accomplished novels here I refer to the
works from another country first
published in 1962 to just above my head
James Baldwin's Turkish decades restores
those challenging admittedly did
called absolutely complex works back to
Baldwin's cannon as the experimental
works they truly are James Baldwin's
Turkish decade is I hope you can
appreciate a deservedly award-winning
book I'm certain that MOG does
forthcoming study me and my house James
Baldwin and black domesticity
forthcoming in 2017 awesome will be
groundbreaking in its own right too her
talk today draws from that project
erasure overlay manipulation James
Baldwin's queer dwellings please join me
in welcoming professor Magdalena's of
Roscoe to Yale
good evening everyone can you hear me
thank you if I ever go low please signal
especially people sitting in the back
I want to thank Jackie for this lovely
generous introduction and I'm really
happy to be here and I want to thank all
the people whose names I cannot possibly
remember and and mention here for
preparing my visit and for making it
possible and especially to mr. and mrs.
Frankie for the series of which I am so
probably a part of also to Phoenix who
has taken care of me beautifully
including dragging my bag and computer
and books to this place in this talk I
will try to give you a sense of what my
book talks about and very quickly my
archive is incredibly eclectic so I look
at salvaging books objects artwork left
from Baldwin's house in sample device in
the South of France and my concern is to
really try to preserve the matter the
material traces of black life because it
matters because we need this project of
preserving and recovering these remnants
so I'm spinning three to larger concepts
here and they will circulate through the
narrative of the talk the matter has to
do with architecture with physical
environment with objects with how things
really are part of our lives the second
part is the material or life story
biography what we make of Baldwin's life
his various locations and thirdly the
metaphor I like alliterations how
Baldwin's writing reflects his domestic
environment the objects he interacted
with but also the stories people told
about him the stereotypes he had to
encounter
and I want to begin with two quotations
in addition to a song which you will
hear in a moment that really locate
Baldwin and his musings on his place in
the nation in the National House of the
United States if you will and on the
other hand on being a very private very
domestic person as a writer as a queer
black man
if I am a part of the American house and
I am it is because my ancestors paid
striving to make it my home so
unimaginable a price and I have seen
some of the effects of that passion
everywhere I have been all over this
world when home drops below the horizon
it rises in one's breast and acquires
the overwhelming power of menaced love
both of these from the wonderful 77
essay every good-bye ain't gone and now
let's listen to a brief clip of Bessie
Smith before a blues
in James Baldwin's 1961 interview with
Studs Terkel recorded soon after the
second collection of Baldwin's essays
nobody knows my name had been published
we hear about how the famous blues
singer Bessie Smith became the young
black risers creative inspiration Terkel
begins their conversation by playing the
opening bars of Smith's popular
backwater blues which floods the air
with images and sounds of ceaseless rain
and the singers persona stranded in her
house like a prisoner of the elements
waiting for about to rescue her cause my
house fell down and I can't live there
no more
somewhat breathlessly baldwin explains
how much smith's blues in a way of
performing them shaped his desire
to be a writer the first time I ever
heard this record was in Europe and
under very different circumstances than
I had ever listened to Bessie in New
York and what struck me was that she was
singing about a disaster which had
almost killed her and she accepted it
and was going beyond it it's a fantastic
kind of understatement it is the way I
want to write by the end of her song
Smith's persona has been rescued and
left up on some high old lonesome hill
overlooking the water and her collapsing
house she sings about being stranded
along with thousands of people ain't got
no place to go
but feeling all alone shocked and stuck
and here's another clip please forgive
me I have to move it up a bit
Oh
ah
no backwater blues Dan called me to pack
my things and go hmm I can't move no
more hmm I can't move no more there
ain't no place for a poor old girl to go
though she needs to flee she is
immobilized in grief and numbness she's
homeless
alone with her song atop a hill
amid the flood a somewhat similar scene
one illustrating how these blues images
of lost home and desire for writing the
way Smith sang stayed with Baldwin for
decades appears in his last novel just
above my head 1979 which takes place in
Harlem the American South and Western
Europe although narrated by a man who
tells his brothers story it features a
complex black woman Julia Miller who is
key to the book several braided plot
lines and in my reading embodies the
story of the homeless and lonesome woman
from Smith's backwater blues a child
preacher prodigy Julia is so spoiled by
her parents that she rules them her
refusal to let her seriously ill mother
see a doctor until it is too late
costs the mother's life orphaned at 14
Julia is left alone with her cruel
alcoholic father who rapes her and when
she becomes pregnant beats her nearly to
death like that of Bessie Smith blues
woman's Julia's disaster is of biblical
proportions like the flood it
obliterates her home and almost kills
her Baldwin's descriptions illustrate
Julia's tragedy with metaphors that
echoes miss lyrics home was not a place
she wanted to go but she had no place
else to go with all her heart she wanted
to flee she could not move she was
sitting still watching everything
crumble and disappear she had to move
and yet she waited with all her heart
she wanted to flee she could not move
she could not move and yet she knew she
must soon it would be too late
she would begin to die Baldwin narrates
Julia's tragedy through elegiac
rewriting of Smith's lyrics cadence and
imagery and by means of other characters
tales about her like Smith's blues
Julia's story revolves around a tragic
loss of home and her lone efforts to
survive and heal the trauma of her
childhood
unlike Smith's persona who ends up
stranded at the end of the song however
Julia does learn how to move and to go
on she travels away from the United
States and forges domestic spaces
wherever she can find peace and safety
in the end having accepted her tragic
origins she finds herself at home and
becomes a home to others in her
community like Smith's blues woman Julia
confronts and combats her tragic erasure
indeed she writes herself beyond the
disaster and into a new life standing at
the core of Baldwin's last epic novel
Julia's story is among many throughout
his over that offer moving profound
alternatives to traditional mid 20th
century models of African American
domestic city and of course to stock
images of white picket fence home in
dominant American national culture
little noted today the majority of the
writers works engaged too powerfully
interlinked themes related to this
complex subject first the necessity to
survive away from one's home and
difficult childhood and second the
desire and passion to create alternative
kinds of domestic city and modes of
dwelling for black bodies that do not
fit gender sexual familiar religious or
social norms rules and designs a
powerful lens through which to read
Baldwin's works and their complex
biographical and autobiographical
context today these two themes overlay
and transform the stories of erasure and
loss of home and identity central to his
over these two domestic themes of
survival of family origins and of
creation of alternative dwellings gain
particular urge
see in Baldwin's later works that he
wrote following his Turkish decade and
having settled in the South of France in
if Beale Street could talk the devil
finds work just above my head the
evidence of things not seen and
especially his last unpublished play the
Welcome Table
these gained particular agency these
later works engage in deeper and more
complex genre experimentation than those
he wrote prior to 1971 while also
offering bolder autobiographic
revelations concerning the circumstances
of his personal pain and authorial
anguish reflections on his early
childhood and family home as well as the
deep conflict with his stepfather that
left blasting trauma in that sense like
Bessie Smith's blues woman they voiced
the centrality of the personal always
been political of one's art and life
merging overlapping and creating new
literary and literal entities Baldwin's
later works were just stated and written
in his last and longest lasting house in
some fold advance in the South of France
the relative stability of this domestic
abode allowed him to refer in more
intimate detail to his coming-of-age as
a young lower-class
artist in Harlem in Greenwich Village
and to document his search for writing
havens and modes of dwelling outside of
his home country in the 1976 volume of
essays on of all things in a mine
popular culture the devil finds work and
such singular pieces as essays every
goodbye ain't gone notes on the house of
bondage freaks and the American ideal of
manhood later retitled as here be
dragons and to crush the serpent before
that period while living temporarily in
France Switzerland Turkey Puerto Rico or
England Baldwin had tried to create
dwellings however transitory that helped
him to script a story that would
accommodate both his complex authorial
and private identities of what we might
call the complexity of black queer
nested
of course resistance to labels Baldwin
saw himself simply as a sum of his
multiple strange selves as a black
American man who loved some men and some
women as he proclaims in Sadat Park eyes
1973 Turkish film James Baldwin from
another place in the same film he also
mentions a curious sensation while
talking about the discovery of his
sexual difference during his youth
Baldwin emphasizes that he felt so
profoundly alone so marginalized and
singled out as a black gay man in Harlan
that it seemed as if he had no mother
and no father as if he had no antecedent
filmed in 1970 by Sadat pokai insight
Baldwin's cozy writing studio in
Istanbul this statement links loneliness
and homelessness as inevitable
conditions for someone who is both black
and queer and also an artist describing
himself as an orphan with no ancestry is
a symbolic act of course for Baldwin
this is his artist statement and of
course this statement puts him in the
same boat so to speak with Bessie
Smith's homeless blues woman while also
anticipating the story of Julia Miller's
loss and survival to come in just above
my head Baldwin's pairing of the two
conditions loneliness and homelessness
has inextricably connected to American
black queerness and his own art as a
writer should not be taken lightly for
its signals the painful process of
becoming James Baldwin in the last
century the heart process of claiming
one's identity no matter how different
from what was and is accepted at home
the relevance of Baldwin's vision
endures today as many of us who are
considered other still find their
processes of becoming or simply being
like so so hard and so painful a
singular genius and a complex and often
baffling human being like so many of us
James Baldwin is now bearing the role of
the larger
life ancestor and antecedent for the
LGBTQ AI communities indeed it can be
said that his works and vision have
created a capacious home a deeply
literary man woman blues for us all in
the next part of this presentation I
will talk briefly about Baldwin's queer
dwellings in Switzerland and France as
examples of his literal and literary
manipulation of the concept of house and
home
in places where he lived and the books
he wrote there so first I will highlight
quickly Baldwin's fraught relationship
with a Swiss painter Lucia Harper's
Berger the love of his life and their
home making efforts in an alpine village
where Baldwin finished his first novel
go tell it on the mountain second I will
return to Chevelle Dwayne in France the
writers house which by now has been
partially demolished but which
nevertheless remains a destination for
those earning for material remnants of
that particular writers life I conclude
with a glimpse of black queer utopian
dwelling depicted in Baldwin's last
novel as an example of how he
domesticated his manipulations of
various spaces in his last novel and as
a transition I would like you to look at
a video of the young Warwick singing a
house is not a home this was a record
Baldwin had in his collection and this
is the video that is a very different
take
a chair is still a chain even when
there's no one sitting
you
a room it's the room even when there's
nothing
Oh
so this is a transition and you will see
why an unhappy love story an empty house
and a lover missile in the domestic
space is the topic here so part one on
top of the mountain Baldwin's aren't
enough relationship with Lucy hoppers
burger the love of his life began in
Paris about 1949 and ended at Shay
Baldwin were hoppers burger visited many
times and where he stayed in the fall of
1987 until the writers death taking care
of his former lovers ravaged body as his
nurse their story of unrequited love and
unfulfilled black queer domestic desire
on the part of Baldwin and of betrayal
but also persistent platonic love for
Baldwin on the part of Harper's burger
is an important addition to the larger
cachet of stories mapping transnational
American cultures the stories in which
longing for home as Haven intersects
with erotic desire race and class with
private and public social spaces and
African diasporic and West European
histories when Baldwin met Harper's
burger it was soon after the stolen
sheep incident described vividly in his
essay equal in Paris this is what
Harper's burger tells me in an interview
in 2007 all Americans were stars than in
Paris in the 50s and I needed to learn
English he is a tall man with gray hair
receding quite a bit now and a cheerful
manner born in 1932 he is 75 and laughs
loudly recalling that he was 17 years
old then a young naive kid who knew
nothing of races in Harlem but who was
very curious when he ran into Baldwin
they had a drink and spoke French and
then perhaps without quite realizing
what exactly he was doing Lucien found
himself the love of James's life the
role he could never fully embrace after
the first couple of years we share
drinks
eating when we could we had some good
friends who did some great cooking he
was in love with Baldwin given his
belief in what he now terms male
homosexuality everything was natural in
what we did he tells me all of this was
new to me I'm sorry but I accepted it
completely Baldwin's race his
homosexuality that he was attracted to
me
Baldwin was a difficult friend and a
difficult lover after about six months
in Paris he was simply unable to write
harper's Berger explains I didn't know
what I was doing I put him up there in
the chalet he says convinced that Jimmy
would write better in the secluded
mountain hovel of lush lebesgue where
his family had a cabin in addition to
securing the Chalet Hussein got some
money from his father to help to pay
their living expenses the only thing he
did not prepare for was his lovers shock
upon arrival as Baldwin writes in the
stranger in the village it did not occur
to me possibly because I am an American
that there could be people anywhere who
had never seen a Negro as Harper's
Berger claims he and Baldwin made three
visits to the village between 1950 and
52 on their first trip they took a
hazardous two day long backpacking trip
to Shannon in the mountains
it was hard Jimmy almost lost his life
on a glacier he recalls and then makes
sure I noticed the relevance of the trip
to the title of Baldwin's first novel
the mountain was there when they worked
up the ice on the glacier the Sun was
hitting Baldwin's face and it was a
biblical metaphor an experience that
counted for both of them
Baldwin managed to finish go tell it
only on their third visit in winter of
1952 when he also worked on the essay
stranger in the village and began
writing his first play the Amen Corner
lucio assures me that no matter how he
felt about it
Baldwin had always
beautiful contact with people there he
charmed them dance with a woman who
owned a bistro there he knew who they
were and he really got his work done but
in the writers account in stranger in
the village The Bistro on owners wife
quote beamed with a pleasure far more
genuine than my own having in front
Baldwin that the village Catholic
Church's collections bought last year
six or eight African natives a custom
that is repeated in many villages for
the purpose of converting them to
Christianity the ignorance of the
villagers incites Baldwin's musings on
slavery in colonial history in his own
situation in the West on to which I have
been so strangely grafted inside the
chalet much in love during their early
visit James and Lucien successfully
Playhouse together as a very strange
couple as Harper's burger joke clearly
states in Corinth Orson's documentary
the price of the ticket Baldwin writes
in stranger in the village that their
isolation from the distractions they so
loved in Paris was nearly complete there
is no movie house no bank no library no
theatre very few radios one Jeep one
station wagon and at the moment one
typewriter mine an invention which the
woman next door to me here had never
seen indeed he apprehends his remoteness
from the United States and other African
Americans in terms of irreconcilable
cultural difference and the simple fact
of social in Geographic space or a
dreadful abyss between the streets of
this village and the streets of the city
in which I was born amid the wintry
landscape surrounded by white faces
Baldwin's typewriter manuscript and
Bessie Smith and Fats Waller records are
the only reminders of his American home
yet it is precisely this remoteness that
allows for a low-key household routine
that guarantees that Jimmy can write all
day while Lucille shops and cooks in the
evenings they go out for walks and
drinks or as Lucy Enrico's fondly I take
him out
they're cozy Chalet is the first
semblance of home baldwin ever shared
with a lover harper's burger describes
it as typical rustic with a little
kitchen and main room with a stone oven
we were always sitting there a little
room next to it very small under us on
the lower floor there was a mother and
wet with a child a horror at that time
in Thorsen's film hoppers burger
remembers vividly the moment when the
novel is finished one day he is
listening to Jimmy's punching out loudly
its final six letters the act as hoppers
Berger tells me in 2007 as if summing up
the surprising conclusion of Baldwin's
essay stranger in the village in largely
been Baldwin could see what culture and
knowledge could do that these people the
villagers are victims of their culture
with their medieval custom of buying
Africans for the Catholic Church he
repeats that Baldwin understood so well
these little people as victims of their
culture being there was a key moment for
him he saw how much he was a modern
human being and they were in the Middle
Ages clearly to Lucia
there was never any doubt that his black
American lover was the intellectual
ingenious in the village one who took
measure of the little people around him
who wrote them up and use them as
literary material rather than being at
least in anyway worth mentioning sized
up by them as a stranger and we know
from the discussion this afternoon there
is with more complexity to this
situation at the end of our conversation
harper's burger is very sad and tells me
that after Baldwin's passing he realized
that if he'd lived I'd help him to go on
I must say I left Jimmy alone at that
time and that's why he was thinking of
suicide at times I think he had no hope
for this world
he quickly reminds me I was there the
last months every day and finally he
tells me how quietly Baldwin passed away
he was serene
someone was reading to him he couldn't
talk we loosened when David Baldwin
James's younger brother and Bernhard
hassel set with him saw him in was him
go he tells me in a low voice with a sad
smile then laughs a low choking laugh
and drinks a toast part two
a house is not a home I first walked
through James Baldwin's former house on
the edge of sample the vans an ancient
town in the South of France in June of
2000 while having only the vaguest
notion of how his works and life story
would soon fill my own inside the house
was quiet cool and shadowy with the
partially shattered windows letting in
slender shafts of sunlight filled with
dust motes as I walked across the sunny
stripes on the floor the melancholy air
of the place struck me I was thinking of
those whose home it once was James
Baldwin his beloved younger brother
David who inherited the house after his
passing the beautiful dancer Bernard
hassel who was their friend and house
manager and died there of AIDS
several years after Baldwin and many
others famous or not who came to visit
and stay a while it also made me think
of those who once tended to its ground
surfaces and objects like Jean ferré its
previous owner and close friend of
Baldwin's or Valerie Sorel who cooked
splendid meals in their kitchen and
served them to Jimmy and his guests at
the table outside near Ann Arbor there
must have been gardeners or
groundskeepers to whose names and
identities I would never know but I
recalled Mohammed the [ __ ]
groundskeeper from Baldwin's last play
the Welcome Table who was based on an
actual person of all the spaces I was
especially mesmerised by what was then
13 years after Baldwin's death left of
his upstairs living room quiet somewhat
dusty with hints of that omnipresent
Mediterranean moisture that curled the
photos tacked to the wall over the
mantle
that space beckoned for some
inexplicable reason - my literary
critical imagination that living room
seemed to hold the most stories memories
and traces of human habitation at first
glance it appeared to be a simple enough
space containing objects one would
expect a rustic wooden table and three
chairs a colorful orange brownish
pinkish throw over the couch with puffy
round pillows maybe Turkish rug under
the table breaking the pattern of the
checkered tile floor on the walls there
were photos posters and framed art not
to mention the storm of pictures and
objects adorning the mantelpiece in the
corner which was dominated by a green
yellow red Nelson Mandela poster the
longer I stood there the more the room
filled with possibility and wonder and
yes with desire and need an important
discovery did not register in that
moment not until I came back to the
house in 2014 was that I had been caught
up in a powerful and collected Baldwin
related sensation that would travel
through time and space I was merely a
predecessor to or perhaps also appeared
after some others who had come and would
continue coming to the site of Baldwin's
house to find that material something
which reading his works alone could not
provide those of us who have been lucky
and privileged enough to be able to make
it to sample the Vance I grid by that
same powerful need and longing to save
something material from the site all of
us scholars intellectuals writers
readers and simply those who loved
Baldwin ironing to fulfill a dream of
being somehow connected to the writer in
ways that go beyond the literary magic
that takes place on the pages of his
text on some level perhaps we must all
believe that the precious matter of that
particular black life which ended in
that house in 1987 could somehow be
salvaged and preserved especially in
light of so few remnants of his
existence and the brutal absence of a
writer's house museum devoted to him in
this country
years ago bowling great Baldwin's great
nice Colima Nazarene traveled to the
house and took hunting black-and-white
pictures others like Douglas field
Thomas Chatterton Williams and Rachel
cardigan saw have written about the
undeniable pool of this particular place
which compelled them to jump over fences
dig up pieces of china from the dirt or
search desperately for other remnants in
all of their accounts this material
hunger is palpable as is the firm and
fervent imagining or even inventing if
necessary of Baldwin's past in his
possessions on the basis of available
illusive evidence hearsay and yes that
thirsty desire to be close to him
reading Baldwin I think makes one greedy
for the matter related to his life for
we have nothing else left of him but his
published works perhaps the
preponderance of digitized photographs
and recorded interviews with Baldwin
online is only magnifying this yearning
for objects for the solidity of things
whose weight and concrete endurance
might afford as a connection with him
that is more substantial more intimate
more worked for than the impersonal
touch of a keyboard or fleeting image on
a screen indeed what I have discovered
is that Baldwin's brass last writing
Haven helps us to push the diet of black
queer further by giving it a socially
special dimension and by modifying it
with two terms that his work has
commanded and inspired domestic and
transnational the former term domestic
arises from the literary focus of my
project on Baldwin's black queer home
spaces from its architectural focus on a
series of images of Baldwin's house in
sampled advance the latter term
transnational has to do with what some
of his readers see as ironic and others
as tragic namely that the writer was
unable to find
in Haven in his home country exiled from
the United States both by circumstance
and choice following his first foray
into European exile in France and Turkey
Baldwin did find his most enduring home
in the unlikely remote village of sample
devons that domestic space allowed for a
nurturing routine that helped him to
slow down in order to take better care
of his ailing health and to remain
productive as a writer academic teacher
and transnational public intellectual
who continued to travel but always
returned home to his Provencal abode as
I mentioned Baldwin died at home in
sampled events in 1987 and Cher Baldwin
was left to his younger brother David
following David's death and several
lawsuits the house was lost to
developers in the early 2000s emptied of
the brothers possessions and deserted
no matter James's dying wish to preserve
it as a retreat for African Diaspora
writers today there is no trace of the
famous American writers presence in the
area no sign no marker no photograph in
the guidebooks as of early November 2014
large parts of the structure were
demolished including the ground floor
section facing the back garden that
contained baldwin study and living
quarters although a partial shell of the
house still endures it seems now as if
James Baldwin the famous
african-american writer has never set
foot in sampled advance that there is no
place in this country that that one can
visit to imagine Baldwin's writing life
to frame with material architecture and
landscape the metaphorical biographical
and literary knowledge we have of him
today is deeply poignant at a time when
the United States boasts of some 70
writers houses that are museums open to
the public while documenting the process
of the erasure of Baldwin's house I also
I'm sorry I also read into its
destruction and emptiness and tease out
from existing material evidence
Baldwin's works letters photographs of
the structure and objects salvaged from
it and plenty of imaginative speculation
that unique overlay or traces of black
we're domestic presence that Baldwin the
transnational african-american writer
and one of the most important literary
figures of the last century has left us
as his legacy the author whose works
touch upon domestic themes with some
regularity throughout his over commented
on the paradox of house and home
as discourse structure and process in a
short autobiographic as I published in
of all places Architectural Digest in
August of 87 just a couple of months
before he died the house is not a home
we have all heard the proverb yet if the
house is not a home home it can become
only a space to be manipulated
manipulation demanding rather more skill
than grace appearing in print about
three months before his death this
statement confirms the importance of his
domestic about to his late works and
compose his readers and critics to
engage in rigorous search for the
sources and effects of the domestic
manipulations that he implies in this
little-known essay Gaston Bachelard
literary critical formulation concerning
our imaginary domain over places we
inhabit links the house image to the
typography of our intimate being
shoveled win can thus be seen both as a
physical space of manipulation for its
owner as Baldwin claims in the
Architectural Digest piece and as a
space offering a visitor a chance to
read their own versions of James
Baldwin's dwelling were in the absence
of any sites in this
country we can conjure up his black
queer domesticity from whatever remains
of his household abroad part three black
queer utopias The Loft stretches the
entire length of the top floor
half-heartedly divided by a clothesline
with a sheet draped over it behind this
sheet is the bed close to the floor
covered with a heavy dark blue blanket
and many loud pillows there is a
bathroom and the rudiments of a kitchen
in the front are Arthur's piano records
tape recording apparatus sheet music
books there is a sofa chairs a big table
on the walls photographs and posters the
last pages of James Baldwin's sixth
novel his last just above my head
glimpse a utopian domestic space
occupied by two black men in love who
are musicians in New York City the older
one is a singer named Arthur and the
younger a pianist named Jimmy as our I'm
sorry this is this should not be
happening
forgive me I have no idea where this
happened the older one is a singer named
author and the younger a pianist named
Jimmy as artistic collaborators as well
as lovers they have created a home
together and the loft is where they live
and work for hours days and months
the labor of music commands their time
it is their progeny though it comes from
the black church were openly black queer
men are usually not welcomed the rituals
and sounds that have framed their
childhood and young manhood in Harlem
and our Father for their creativity work
and love the space they occupy is both
home and Haven it is the only place
where they can be themselves where their
love not only dares to speak but also
sing shout and testify to its name the
interpenetration of artistic domestic
and religious spaces in Jimmy and
Arthur's utopian refuge in just above my
head echoes James Baldwin's own
experience as a budding writer from a
lower-class african-american family in
the United States and his youth in the
Pentecostal tradition of storefront
Harlem churches written largely in his
house in the South of France his last
novel also reflects the more expansive
meditative and improvisational approach
to fiction that he turned to in the
1970s and 80s as the writer describes
this work in the interview with Clayton
Holloway given for the Xavier review in
November 1985 it arose from a series of
short stories that made him realize that
quote within the last 20 years my
attention has been on something which I
cannot handle in a short story I am
involved with a big canvas and that has
been a very big challenge and a kind of
terror the challenges and gestation of
his last novel required that Baldwin not
only embrace new and to him terrifying
approaches in his work the approaches
that he's happy domestic city in the
remote part of France certainly enabled
but that he also confront himself as an
older artist who must as he explains in
this
you interview concur with the process
that begins with apprehension alienation
the sense of being other and therefore
doomed his work is his only hope
as the writer mentions in a letter
written to his younger brother David on
February 6 1979 or the day he thought he
had finished just above my head
he felt torn haunted and uncertain about
this book he was feeling that somehow he
missed it was not quite equal to the
song that he heard and wanted to sing at
the same time as he felt that he did not
cheat and that at the bottom of myself
he also thought that it was his very
best book given the writers tremendous
investment in that last novel it is no
accident then that the two artists
figures who occupy the utopian black
queer home space in just above my head
were their authors first and second
names the room describes in the epigraph
contains furnishings that could have
come from a room in Baldwin's own house
the colors are familiar too resembling
the palette of the author's French about
Hall Montana the narrator and Arthur's
elder brother whose story begins with
him imagining post factum his brother's
death has an epiphany regarding his
situation as he's looking at the ceiling
of his bedroom the ceiling whose
description fits exactly the one
involved winds housing some older vans
specifically in his no longer existing
living quarters whitewashed with heavy
exposed and painted beams in that novel
Baldwin's French house becomes part of
the physical setting as well as making
the writing of its plot and characters
possible as the space of authorial labor
in the writings process material
circumstances often follow metaphysical
visions and vice-versa for the scene
with the ceiling moving down just above
the narrator
had in the novel was inspired by an
actual dream that the writer had at his
shed baldwin bedroom in 1975 on the same
night his younger brother David who was
staying at the house - dreamt of
characters in search of an author
the brothers dreams the house and an old
gospel song up above my head I hear
music in the air came together to make
what Eleanor trailer turns in her review
as the story both dreadful and beautiful
a tale told consistently by the Baldwin
narrator witness quite fittingly his
last novel reveals Baldwin concerned
more than ever with the familiar
elements of his writing his own and his
people's stories past and present that
are often traumatic but also
increasingly with matters spiritual and
esoteric dreams premonitions revelations
our libraries and parables that should
be seen as important I'll be it under
explored signatures of his late style
and central to his last decade filled
with experimentation and play within and
without African diasporic artistic forms
while that complexity and terror that it
inevitably brought about in his writing
process had been Baldwin's intense focus
throughout his life he insisted on
making sexuality and especially male
queer sexuality as important as the
issues of race and class in his
representations of black American
subjectivity of all of his works just
above my head deals with black queerness
and sexuality in general most openly
daringly at the same time that it makes
clear the deep prejudice against
same-sex desire in the community country
and the wider world around Arthur and
Jamie the domestication of their bond
however should lived in the novel also
marks a turning point in 20th century
American literary representations of
Magnusson queerness one that academic
theory has caught up to only fairly
recently as Patrick Johnson and me
Henderson defined the field of black
queer studies that has claimed Baldwin
as its military ancestors for over a
decade
I'm sorry as it's literary ancestor for
over a decade two queer queer to throw
shade on its meaning in the spirit of
extending of extending its service to
blackness as they emphasize both both
terms black and queer are markers of
signifiers of difference so we endorse
the double-cross of affirming the
inclusivity mobilized under the sign of
career while claiming the racial
historical and cultural specificity
attached to the marker black that's a
mouthful as we all can see I hope by now
Baldwin hit this theory decades earlier
and explained it more in more compelling
ways to conclude Baldwin's wondrous
manipulations of black queer domesticity
resulted from what many of his American
critics and readers on both sides of the
color line did not like at the time or
from his artistic desire to offer a more
humane queer alternative to merciless
Western narratives of the so called
progress in civilization Baldwin does
this work with Gaston by writing strange
blackness himself and his personal story
of homelessness and loneliness that
black women writers first sang to him in
their blues as a central corrective
presence into the late 20th century
narrative of American national identity
Baldwin's private black queer attempts
at home making outside of the United
States continued to resonate in his
works with an urgent public task of
rewriting both the story of Western
colonial dominance and the story of the
American national house from the
brilliant complex and often painful but
absolutely necessary vantage point of
African Diaspora that he has made
uniquely his own
thank you so much nidiffer that
wonderful talk those are wonderful um so
we have time for questions comments
insights the different photos that were
obviously cardboard boxes and so so the
I'm I'm not allowed to talk about this
person's identity but she was involved
with Baldwin's brother and when the
family lost the house to a lawsuit they
had less than 24 hours to empty the
house which contained all of Baldwin's
books all of his brothers artwork all of
the photos and files for example a whole
box of files he used to research the
evidence of things not seen his last
essay volume all of this because it
wasn't exactly manuscript which is the
you know the precious in the economics
of literary inheritance this is the
precious possession right this is the
stuff that brings in money so all of
Baldwin's manuscripts notes had been
removed but his library his magazines
his journals that he read regularly
boxes of Xerox copies of various pieces
of research he used for his work that
they were left there and they would have
gone to the dumpster if this person
hasn't basically paid her own money to
save them and to store them and I was
lucky enough to meet her and obtain her
permission to document them and it's
very fortuitous we have archivists from
the vinery here because perhaps there is
a way to save some of this material
she's basically ready now to sort of get
rid of it and and make sure it finds a
good home so in a nutshell that's the
story
other questions comments I'm struck by a
quote by Baldwin when he says that you'd
better take your home with you otherwise
you're homeless and I wondered how you
would relate that quote to what you
you're very eloquent perceptions thank
you that's that's a quote that's in your
documentary this is Karen Thorson the
director of the documentary the price of
the ticket and this this is an amazing
one of those things to put on a t-shirt
on a hashtag you take you home with you
so who you are who you were born with we
had a great discussion the students
present here made fantastic comments on
that very theme in the class today you
take who you are with you your roots
even the trauma even the pain of your
origins comes with you you cannot share
it you cannot get rid of it and of
course in American cultural narratives
you think of immigrant narratives you're
supposed to go through a melting and
share your identity and become a new
entity and that happens too to a degree
but you never really lose who you are I
think there is a layering reformulating
recreating manipulating indeed
overlaying of all these selves and
histories and stories so so yes it's
your decision to be homeless or to be
perceived as homeless and I think
homelessness really makes the importance
of memory of being uprooted of having a
geographic place we are all accidents of
genetics and geography right but we all
can trace our beginnings to a certain
place and certain people
to explain the your own architecture
argument by way the three terms of ratio
manipulation and wonder could you say a
little bit more about how you see them
as a part of what kind of building
system to continue to conceive do you
see them as discrete operations in
Baldwin's especially thinking about the
late novels after 71 the writing after
71 which I would agree gets even more
expansive than 62 to 70 or so but do you
see erase your overlay manipulation as
distinct elements of a system or how do
how do you envision them interacting
because it was a neat way to kind of
schema ties the talk but I was wondering
as a systems there's a theory of an
architecture for the novel because
that's in some level what you're
building towards it seems to me how do
you see those those concepts
I think they exist simultaneously and
this is where you see Baldwin juggling
multiple elements of identity you know
we talk about intersectionality and we
get there somewhere in the 90s in
academic discussions and theories but
he's very much aware of it as he
constructs his artistic vision and
changes and amends it so the sense of
erasure and and again the matter of
black lives there has been some
preservation of it and I'm speaking of
it having been recently to the soft
opening of the new National Museum of
african-american history and culture but
then there is also so little that is
preserved there is so much that is lost
and for him as one of the most important
writers of the last century not only in
this country but throughout the world it
is painful to see how he touched so many
places and yet we can find more traces
of his presence in Turkey than in the
United States so that sense of erasure
of material remnants of traces of
imprints of black life is one of the
issues that he talks about in the number
my work in the world in the work that
I'm doing the overlap is that creativity
is that desire to save it and to do
something with it and in that sense
Baldwin realizes that like his stay in
Turkey he stay in France in his late
life brought new qualities brought new
ways of seeing to him
so then what he considers his past and
his story gets overlaid with new
entities with new quantities and
qualities and then finally the
manipulation is that amazing genius he
has of spinning all these things
together into literature so just above
my head I know the students are heading
towards that novel so if I make give any
of it away right now is that people
hated this novel because they didn't
know how to read it and yet if you think
through all these things and Baldwin
spinning multiple themes and again think
of the songs and the women singing the
songs and the glamour but also the pain
and and the form used to convey the pain
you begin to see a very careful design
to all this sort of seeming jazz
improvisation that's how people kind of
dismiss just above my head it's a jazz
improvisation but what about it how does
it come about and and of course you know
the obsessive compulsive academic thing
that we do in our work I worked with
this novel so intensely and so closely
that I see it all but it's taken me you
know at least ten readings very close
readings of it to get there so to sum it
up what Baldwin's asks of us what
Baldwin's asks of himself and and
delivers so incredibly is this really
hard work is really labor labor of
reading but also labor of understanding
people of seeing them of listening to
them of seeing each person for who she
it they are it's it's an incredible
humanistic project that I think is
something that we need desperately need
today I mean I don't have to tell you
how much we needed today
those pictures you showed from 2000 to
2014 I think they were mainly yours it
was a very poignant to see literally the
erasure of his home and it was one I
remember particularly you had the
ceiling it was kind of ornate and that
it was just gone I was white you know
he's not Zola or Balzac but did the
French government ever express any
interest in stopping this or preserving
this unfortunately not until this time
and now there is a foundation and if you
go to the well dr. Google is his house
in Provence the the organization is not
able to use Baldwin's name his house in
Provence is a budding Foundation
movement by some activists who are
trying to save what remains of the house
so what they managed to do somebody
occupied the house for a while that they
had to be removed by police now the
French government at least halted the
destruction but the developer who owns
the property it is a very expensive
property by now wants to put villas and
swimming pools there to you know to make
a lot of money it's it's one of those
prime real estate pieces you know most
expensive in the region so the economics
of it on the one hand and on the other
the cultural imperative to preserve and
to save are not exactly working hand in
hand so we'll see what happens I I have
a sense though that it will take a while
and again I'm not sure if they would
even want Baldwin's books again the
material I was showing you the boxes and
boxes of the kind of objects that we
don't value usually that's that's what
I'm concerned with that's the last
traces we have a problem
you are immensely interesting so I take
it those came from Baldwin's library yes
all of them there are traces of his I
haven't had a chance to look through
every book and every page so there may
be things I have not seen I saw a lot of
the Xerox material that he worked with
and clearly somebody was doing research
for him because there were some notes
from other people all the manuscripts
letters I found maybe one letter from a
publisher and some manuscripts people
sent him to read and comment on but all
the sort of stuff bearing heavy imprint
of volumes writing was removed but I
have no time going back actually this
this next summer to to do the rest of
the research that is hopefully to go
through every book and see what what I
can find inside them it's interesting
because it calls to mind Gwendolyn
Brooks his papers there's a cache of UC
Berkeley and of the 13 or so boxes
there's one box that it was labeled in
the finding aid greeting cards so you
look at these greeting you know using
this box and there's you know folder
after folder like Hallmark greeting
cards from Gwendolyn Brooks right one of
the major amazing poets of the 20th
century is buying and using Hallmark
greeting cards okay and you could you
could just look at that and and maybe
the evidence you could get from it would
be you know who is she writing to who
constitutes her social network on the
other hand it also gives us a clue into
her rapport with mass culture right she
wasn't above buying a Hallmark card to
communicate to connect with the people
that counted in her life and so having
those material that material evidence of
how writers live and especially how
black writers lived I think is
terrifically important if I just may
yeah comment on that because it's just
you know I get envious frankly of jazz
historians who have this extraordinary
set of archives that document the jazz
creative process from
composition charts to the photographs of
studio sessions the photographs of
concerts you know it seems like there's
not enough but a good body of
autobiographical memoirs that we can
turn to now and this is one reason why
Jazz Studies is thriving in African
American and American Studies I'm happy
for that I'm also jealous of it as a
literary critic precisely because
especially for the mid century authors
well we have a phone log from Baldwin's
house so we have a record over several
weeks of calls and who called and among
them there is one from Karen to talk
about the film and yeah and and there
are calls from David leaving the
biographer and Maya Angelou so you know
you can find a sort of record of
everyday life again that we don't
necessarily pay attention to but as you
said gives us proof of that lives of the
mundane and the importance of the
mundane to that life yeah any other
comments or questions just when you were
speaking about whether somebody might
what the books are not as as you see
what happens as we all see what happens
with the house and government and so
forth we have a friend that works in the
US with the National Trust for Historic
Preservation and we were hearing about a
Louis Armstrong house and what was
interesting is it was just the
preservation of domesticity here's where
he kept his medicine and it really the
whole you know the whole idea was this
sense of how a person lived and part of
the stunning aspect is a kind of a
nondescript place and here are the
objects around him and what you
considered is genius this magic it's a
person who works every day and it's very
inspiring to see that I can imagine
those books being incredibly important
especially a writer who would visit and
say oh this is just the way I work all
this stuff lying around and it's
simmering and percolating and starts to
inform my work I think it's tremendously
valuable I understand the manuscripts
are high-priced items that travel around
like a painting with somebody obvious
but this other stuff is that's how it
got made and I tell you I mean I opened
the box and there were there was every
novel by Edith Wharton and I said oh my
gosh everyone WIPs estimated them there
was Alice Walker there was Toni
Morrison's beloved which he started
reading didn't finish he wanted to
finish before he died he didn't get to
it there were books there were black
Christian gay magazines about whose
existence I never knew several issues of
them but there was of course black
scholar but there was also a Bernie
there was Jet magazine there were very
popular culture items as well and and
you know books about France and Provence
and tour guides but also history volumes
but also books on costumes in Africa and
the Caribbean incredibly sort of
interesting reading range and and that
really was very valuable to me because
it confirmed what I was told by so many
of Bobo's friends that he read
everything please remember the man never
went to college he finished his
education at they would Clinton High
School in in the Bronx that was it and
yet he he was so order didactic and so
devoted to work literature that he
devoured everything that got written so
he read the theory he but he also you
know he read Dostoevsky he cut his see
some Dickens as a small kid and he was
able to turn remember Dickens not
exactly friendly to black people writer
he is able to turn Dickens's
descriptions of poverty of children of
misery of pain into valuable material
for his future own craft so I think
exactly those mundane often neglected
objects reading material are actually
key to getting a full picture to getting
a full portrait of the artist
anymore the last thought yeah thank you
so much thank you